this session is a little different today
it's interesting I was being interviewed
by Kate
w this morning and in the middle of the
interview we were talking about what's
going on in Asia and Asia
entrepreneurship and Asian in a patient
and the host Alan Olson said so what is
Asia innovation mean for the Silicon
Valley and that's exactly the theme of
our talk today right we've got three
Silicon Valley entrepreneurs and their
ventures as will here are really Silicon
Valley ventures but we're looking for
the Asia connections what is it about
Asia that has influenced either the
pattern of procuring funding or other
resources for the venture or the whole
market opportunity for the venture or
even possibly just the cultural
background that maybe you know in in
some ways all of our panel are
international people I'm very happy that
we have a great panel today sitting
closest to me as David Bruner and I've
known David for about 14 years since he
was a student at Stanford and since
being a student at Stanford and one of
the organizers of the very first
asia-pacific student entrepreneurship
society summits at Stanford David went
on to get a doctorate in from Harvard
University and also to write about
entrepreneurship in Japan and is now in
the middle of the angel round the first
round of a venture here sitting next to
David is Jim nuyen and Jim was a contact
from several years ago we've been on
some of the same programs together but i
want to say especially that Jim was
recommended to me for this session by
Jeremy potash who is the executive
director of the California Asia Business
Council so I want to thank Jeremy for
her help in putting this seminar
together today and I especially want to
say thanks to Jim for coming over and
talking to us he will present his car
venture which is kinda calm KY in d ed
calm and farthest away from me is you
Kai chow who's been on a number of our
programs before you kai is really a
serial entrepreneur having done several
ventures in the Silicon Valley area
coming from Taiwan to the US right and
youkai until recently was the CEO of a
company called reward me and he's really
an expert in the whole area of
gamification so I think we've got a
great panel what I'm going to ask is for
each of our panelists in turn to kind of
give prepared remarks while you're
giving prepared remarks we'll sit down
and watch your slides okay David why
don't you go first okay could we bring
up the few that's it no actually these
are but I give the wrong so yeah so im-
the Acrobat yeah sure it does work
better with the right slides okay there
you go
good afternoon my name is David Brenner
as for Richards generous introduction so
let me start with just a few words of
about myself I am a local Silicon Valley
boy born and raised in los altos my
father bounced around startup so I heard
over dinner table conversations about
VCS and Sand Hill Road and all that
stuff before coming to Stanford I came
to Stanford I did an undergraduate
degree in computer science along the way
I became interested in Japan I stopped
out for a year and went to Shizuoka
University on a ministry of education
scholarship and then I joined the Tokyo
office of the boston consulting group i
actually got an offer from the San
Francisco office I said you know I'd
really like to start in Japan and they
said you can't do that nice and please
okay go talk to the partners in Tokyo
and see if they'll like you and they
they were kind enough to let me start
there which was probably the most
difficult of experience in my life with
the possible exception of my current
venture so I started in Tokyo I then
came back to San Francisco and after
doing that for two years I went on to
get my doctorate in a PhD program at
Harvard that was joint between computer
science and business unfortunately it no
longer exists anymore but it was the
program and information technology and
management I wrote a dissertation that I
called computer-assisted organizing
after finishing that off I thought about
going into academia but realized I
couldn't really focus on IT because no
other top tier business schools really
have IT departments and although I'm an
organization theorists by training I
wasn't willing to give up the Japan and
the IT angles so I hung around Stan
Harvard for a year as a researcher along
the way and this I'll talk about it more
in a moment I got connected with Shinsei
Bank in Tokyo I worked with them sort of
as a researcher sometimes in residence
studying their enterprise IT systems I
connected with the Tokyo foundation
where I'm currently a visiting fellow
working on their project on corporate
governance and corporate social
responsibility and most recently i'm the
CEO and founder of module q which i
launched in 2011 we raised a seed round
in 2011-12 we're now raising a bridge
round
which we hope will close next Friday I
don't want to jinx that but so far so
good uh so on Richard mentioned that I
have some connections to Japanese
entrepreneurship let me touch on that
just briefly while an undergrad I
connected with professor edward
Feigenbaum who is in the audience with
us today who took me to japan my first
second trip to japan to do research on
japanese entrepreneurship we wrote a
book together on the japanese
entrepreneur and the troubles they face
and I'm actually rather nervous standing
up here because in the manuscript for
that book I had some embarrassing
spelling errors and he threatened to
call up the University and have my
dessert and my degree revoked so I hope
we won't have too many errors in my
slides today or I may lose some of my
credentials but after graduating and
finishing my time at BCG I spent a
summer working with the kyoto
prefectural government on
entrepreneurship promotion some of you
may recognize the kyoto prefecture flag
up there if you're Japan buffs and
learned that if there is going to be an
entrepreneurial rebirth in Kyoto it will
not be driven by the kyoto prefectural
government and a few other things more
recently i'll just mention one because
it has to do with these asia connections
my dear friend izumo who was a
participant in the 1st asia pacific's to
not renew ship summit here at Stanford
has been an inspiration to me throughout
my career that's him selling a euglena
latte as part of his startup in Japan
euglena is a an algae that can be
converted into jet fuel and the euglena
latte is milk with LJ mixed in so I'll
let you think about that one so let me
now talk just briefly oh yeah i forgot
the punchline of that story actually
euglena went public in december there
now valued as of yesterday at about 1.5
billion dollars i follow them pretty
closely so the problem that that we've
set out to solve at module Q is a
problem around email so email was never
designed to be a process management
technology but it's used de facto to
manage just about every ad hoc or ill
structured business process and so what
we're doing with module Q is building a
lair Overeem
that integrates into email it helps you
keep track of what's going on so keep
using email for the stuff that doesn't
matter but if it matters put it through
module Q so it'll be tracked and
organized so you'll get a dashboard
something like this showing you the
balls that are in your court that you
need to take action on the things you've
hit to other people and delegated that
you're waiting for other people act on
and everything else so that's all the
pitch I'll give you I i know we have
limited time so I want to move on to how
Japanese or how entrepreneurship in Asia
fits into this whole story and so I'm
going to give you an a a quantitative
perspective and a qualitative
perspective the quantitative perspective
touches on on Richards comments about
fundraising it has a sample of one which
I will tell you is very unrepresentative
of the broader population but for what
it's worth here's a profile of module
Q's financing to date a significant
majority of our angel investors either
are Japanese or have a connection to
Japan and of the amount of funds a
substantial chunk is from Japanese
nationals I found that if you think
Japanese well-to-do Japanese individuals
are risk averse think again they're
they're a great source of angel
financing if you have the relationships
and folks with Japan connections and the
comment that I'll make here and we might
return to this i'm not sure later in the
panel is that there is a benefit i have
found in fundraising to having access to
a diversity a diverse pool of
prospective investors especially because
here in Silicon Valley what you're doing
today might not be hot and it might take
two years until people decide that
actually enterprise technology is
interesting when I started module q
nobody wanted to hear about the
enterprise everyone one wanted to hear
about social networks now no one wants
to hear about social networks everyone
wants to hear about enterprise so having
that diverse global pool to draw on was
pretty helpful let me now give you a
qualitative view of why I think Asian
entrepreneurship matters this is going
to be a little impressionistic and I
won't be able to go into the details but
I want to get try to get across this
idea that there's some global
cross-pollination that can happen with
ideas and that that can be really
important for startups so our story
starts in India where a
an extraordinary individual named JJ
aveti got his degree in industrial
engineering and then in part because of
his large posture and a large frame and
experienced crushing unions got
recruited by Citibank to protect their
banks in a war zone in the Middle East
which taught him that he could go around
citibank solving their difficult
problems so he moved on to switzerland
and then Japan and ran into a guy named
Masamoto yeah all who turned out to
be the guy that ripple would holdings
tapped when they needed a CEO to run the
collapse long-term credit bank of japan
which they resuscitated as Shinsei bank
and if you're interested in our story up
to this point i strongly recommend
saving the sun by gillian tett a great
book about this story in which both Jay
and Yoshi dose on feature prominently
after yesterday's on resigned a Harvard
man by the name of Terry portait took
over he took a look at what Jay was
doing an IT and didn't really understand
it actually nobody really understands
Jay but that seems to be part of the
brilliance but Jay managed to take the
bag from mainframes to off-the-shelf
dell servers in less than a year on
under 50 million dollars us when audited
quotes were saying 500 million with no
screw-ups and so Terry said to the folks
at Harvard you might want to take a look
at this and some Harvard Business School
researchers wrote a great article called
radically simple IT which has been an
inspiration to me and one of the
co-authors was a a doctoral student
named Brad stops who was a colleague of
mine and said David you should really
get to know Jay so you can see there's
lots of things bouncing around here so I
went out to Japan and got to know Jay
and also got to know his lieutenant
Peter Franken who went to Japan a
Dutchman who went to Japan after college
to work on the fifth generation project
which professor Feigenbaum wrote a book
about and he loves Japan and loves
technology and so after the tsunami he
started an organization called safecast
hacking together ipods ipod geiger
counters that let you measure radiation
with your iphone & crowd sword do
crowd-sourced radiation measurements and
they've just created the first at least
to my knowledge Geiger counter drone so
Peter happens to be
and friends with ian macfarlane who is
the former chief technology officer at a
company called pivotal labs now is
affiliated with digital garage which is
joey itõs company in japan and now with
the San Francisco office connected with
neo and that brings you back to us
because neo will very likely do the
development of our iOS app or help with
that so the punch line to this long and
winding story is that everyone here was
somehow reach their goals through some
kind of entrepreneurial endeavor their
paths all led in some way through Asia
and almost everyone that I've talked
about is in has in some way been
essential to the creation and growth of
module queue up to this point either by
providing ideas advice or capitals so
for almost everyone I showed you I could
tell a long story about how they were in
critical critical in the process I can't
given our time constraints but I hope
you get the idea that there's just a lot
of cross-pollination that can go on so
with that I'll conclude and i look
forward to taking your questions in the
penalty short that kind of amazingly
global
I think it's absolutely more and more
common because the kind the way that
these people work together and the way
that they create their global
connections could not have happened
without IT we routinely collaborate on
skype we work long distance across
continents my investor pool is
distributed around the world my advisors
are distributed around the world and
these individuals work that way too so
people have gotten used to telepresence
as a substitute for actual presence and
they've gotten used to having a global
expertise supply chain okay let's call
it an in for this from now on ask Jim
generally you'll come up and give us
some they'll take care of it everyone my
name is Jim Wynn i'm the co-founder and
president of kind it very glad to be
here i want to recognize some people in
the room I have my CFO Elizabeth peers
here I have my two students from Germany
who i'm teaching culture management we
finished with our finals but they came
here to to listen to me so thanks for
coming thanks a dr. Richard Dasher for
inviting me and appreciate the
opportunity you know when Richard call
me and say hey I'm counting on you to
come in and give a talk I made a
checklist of things that he wants to
make sure that I check off you know when
I talked right and so in my in my brief
remark you see that hopefully i will
church all these points here you know
did i receive funding from asian sources
yes benefits from the networks of
business contact in asia yes so do i see
an opportunity in asia markets for
companies like myself yes and you know
what are the recognized elements of asia
culture as having influenced my path as
an entrepreneur also yes okay so we go
through this so you know i began my
career after college working for the
mayor of san francisco i was doing my
mba / st. Mary's and I you know I had
this this idea that hey you know Sam
Cisco Vietnam is doing under the embargo
now what can we do
set up relationship with Vietnam and so
like you know Sam schools always the
pioneer in opening up relations with you
know with difficult government and I
learned through my research at Sam
scoffs and you know business people send
people who do humanitarian work to
Vietnam at the time and all was under
the radar and so I wrote in mayor I said
you know and my boss and I said you know
is there a way that we can set up a
sister city with Saigon with ho chi minh
city and they invited me in and within
six months i was brought on board and i
was a rising star because I came in and
I said up the program from scratch and
you know I was known as you know writing
speeches for mayor when he goes to
Southeast Asia and stuff like that and I
thought my career was riding high right
I became so like the Vietnam expert in
the mayor's office and throughout the
Bay Area and one day I woke up and this
happened my mayor let me see you I can
play my Mayor was a through a dare you
know a stunt right took a picture with
two radio jockeys in a shower and I
thought oh my god so there goes my
career so with the new mayor on board he
changed policy of course we still have
this is a relationship with with with
Saigon but he exiled me to the ferry
building I don't know you ever been to
the slanted or these nice restaurant in
the ferry building that was where office
was and I was only two people left from
the meat from the previous
administration and he and I were invited
back only like a round you know staff
meeting every tuesday at nine o'clock
other than that we were not welcome that
was when i had this this idea that you
know what I I don't like politics it's
really sad and and it's oppressive and
all that so I linked up with a friend of
mine and he is now also my co-founder we
started this company called plexus net
and flexing that develop these back in
the late 90s from 98 to 2001 if you went
to high tech shows in Vegas like Comdex
net winter up and Apple one and on it we
developed the backend for these guys we
had 27 you know I raised four point six
million dollars with my co-founder and
we were
riding high had end up with 75 people
had office in Hong Kong Singapore Boston
and august two thousand one I think I
everything collapse you know deutsche
bank called me up and say hey yeah Jim
no go and he and I were the last one to
turn off the light that was at that bomb
then I got recruited to work at mercury
news I was there for close to two years
and even during that time I still have
this burning dream of you know doing
something relate to Vietnam which which
I jump at the opportunity after i left
the mayor's office so my first start
after flexes net was pops pops came into
the Vietnam market at the time when it
was really difficult for licensing
production companies licensing companies
to make any kind of money in Vietnam
because if you download ringtones ring
back tones full audio songs this all
pirated right we were the first company
to go in we sign license with EMI with
Sony universal and we convince those
guys to do deal with us so that we can
go and do deal with the local mobile
carriers and so within a couple years
you know we became known as soar like
the the music aggregator the
international content aggregator for
Vietnam because of travel and Families
you know I turned over the company to to
my partner she's running it right now
and pops is really riding high like
number one in Vietnam in terms of being
a mobile they also making mobile games
now mobile entertainment company in the
first year and a half I race 1 million
dollars and we talk about a little bit
through angels here and mostly a group
of CEOs in the in the valley to a
vietnamese americans who I had some
contact and I went to them and say hey
you know this is really a worthy
investment and you would be very happy
to hear that all the companies that they
provided seed funding for the time they
all gone and we pop system standing so
very happy about that the other 1
million before I left we raised through
a Japanese VC and it was pretty
straightforward dealing with with
Japanese investors but at the time these
Japanese investors didn't want anything
to do with us
presence they just want us to be in
Vietnam having our full presence there
and establish the market there 2012
which last year I started a company
called kind it and go to the next line
and we go back to this is very very
simple my daughter that for backpack at
the airport at the jumps go
international airport last June and two
hours later we came back someone found
it one of those parking guy didn't go
around and give you parking tickets we
call them the evil people in Sam scope
he found he found our backpacking in
there with her iPad her her her homework
her camera and all kind of stuff and I
wanted to thank the guy but I didn't
have a sufficient way to thank him
because I thought a verbal thanks he'll
forget it I said you know if I write a
note to your boss you know maybe you and
your boss you see it so we came back I
talked to my partner we call some
psychologists you know call the people
like Elizabeth refer that you know
really some smart people come in and
brainstorm and says you know how bout we
do better how can we make the thanks
last longer how can we make it more
permanent right right and so we can move
with the system called recognized record
and reward and this is done through your
mobile phone through browser you sent a
kinda Graham to whoever was you know
being kind to you that's what we working
on right now is right now through and
beta development mid-june we have a we
have a private launch and we in the
process of raising the bridge around you
know David sound like he's very close to
closing it we are about four ineke away
the other third company that I'm working
on with a friend of mine is and where
I'm on the board is mostly system and
mostly was really more in contract
manufacturing and design services
outside of all these things I teach
part-time at City College across mark in
communications and inter cultural
management so what it was like you know
I talked with David briefly and David
briefly about you know I want to give
you kind of my personal take on on how I
dealt with these investors just imagine
the profile some of the investments I'm
dealing with right they not they not
that sophisticated a lot of these guys
are self-made
millionaire in Vietnam you know they
went through a very tough time and these
guys are loaded over there right and
they're looking for ways to park the
money here in the US right or they are
looking for different kind of adventures
for them to invest in because in Vietnam
this kind of start where you have a
global potential global play it doesn't
exist right because over there starve
you build things for your regional
market so to me you know going to be in
these investors was the quickest way to
get seed funding assuming you have the
language the person only community
connections right you know I said you
must be willing to travel and have thick
skin because these are very these are
people who made the money in a very
tough way so you have to know how to
navigate the culture part when you deal
with them hepi happy is highly emotional
personal investment you know they they
are not sophisticated they want the safe
way to park the money and so you need to
understand their motivation you need to
understand why they want to invest in
your company they not they don't care
maybe don't care about your software
they don't care about kind it but they
care about where you know to keep the
money safe many of them even though they
not sophisticated when they give you the
money when they invest they hire one of
the best law firm top law firm in san
Cisco to deal with us you know so they
their language may not be a
straightforward but they prefer
structure agreement over handshake okay
and because of a person relationship
they were special relationship to drive
a better deal and that is one thing that
you know entrepreneurs we have to know
how to navigate because you know it's
not that straightforward and and
sometimes they take advantage of the
person relationship to try to to get
more out of you because most of the
business owner by themselves right there
kind of own they the only own Empire you
deal directly with them right they have
local emissary but most of time they
really don't have any power and I say
usually I try to have direct contact
with these guys you may find it strange
but they may ask you to help them with
some other business state in the US you
know they may have some kind of
investment down south they may have you
know
may want to get the kid a job somewhere
they may need to find an apartment they
need to buy a house and so when they
invest money in us they also have all
these like you know little baggage that
we also have to take into account I said
find the people to help you but don't
say no immediately right you don't want
to say no because they give you money
and you want to find a ways to work with
them Carol k long dinner last make a
side trip that's that's to be expected
you know tell your spouse is just
business right many of these guys when
they come here that's their time to you
know do serious business but also to
have some fun and so as entrepreneurs
again you kind of have to know what they
need to an emotive asian and kind of go
along with it just don't get in trouble
with your wife language helps but it's
not the deal breaker you don't
necessarily need to speak Vietnamese or
Chinese or you know the language of the
investor but I think it's important to
team up with someone who is culturally
capable to to work with you the culture
influenced you know to me that the
influence on me being being Asian and
being connected to Vietnam is really you
know I think risk-taking is in my DNA
and I I said probably because of both
thing because at well I stay vietnam by
boat and so when you kind of went
through that you just kind of deal with
things and and you don't take adversity
lying down right maximize personal
connections because of the the years I
spent on mayor's office dealing with
high-level government and so I have a
very long relationship with these people
I maximize them but I don't compromise
my integrity right because many of them
that can have their own agenda I also
see myself as a role model to overseas
entrepreneurs many of these guys you
know they they because it's not
sophisticated they have this this very
fantastical notion of what the US is
like and so I want to be their role
model because I want to show them how to
do it right also chlobo trip and not and
not country or regional right even
though I'm a region from Vietnam I can
develop things for that market I also
see that what I do here has much more of
an impact because what I do here has
wider reach and if I were in Vietnam
what's the influence on my star I think
you know to us we don't
when we bill kind it we all we think
right away well how's this going to work
for the Vietnam market how is it going
to work with the China market so it's
natural for me to say hey Jason natural
market to start or expand the work
ethics and integrity that's that's
automatic always push my people to build
long and lasting relationship with
partners right with investors also we
are very aggressive very very aggressive
in mining the networks that we have in
Vietnam in Asia for investment because
you know as I'm sure David mentioned you
know it's about having that that
immediate access to cash so that you can
you can start your business we can go
over this Q&A but you know this is
really Jay answer one or David to dr.
dashes last question is the special
opportunity you know I believe that many
of us in order to be competitive we have
to be cultural entrepreneur not just
entrepreneur we have to be culture
entrepreneur we have to be a tune to
people of different cultures and how
they think how they operate in order to
get things from them right we have to
build a bridge between Silicon Valley
and Asia right and that's to wait not
only getting investment from them here
inbound but also be no getting their
investment for your story if you plan to
to launch regionally and to me the last
thing is opened up new source of seed
funding you know when I last talked with
David is very difficult to get funding
here for many many reasons right and so
to me having direct connection to some
of the people who willing to park their
cash and they believe in your vision
then it's much easier to get from them
I'll take your Q&A later thank you okay
that's right actually why don't you stay
up front and they don't you come up
front because this is the last set of
slides and you're gonna answer oh you do
that sighs it quickly all right the hand
will love we will use or why oh why you
got a mac right yeah all right we're in
business
after seeing all the pretty slides the
past two years speakers had you know I
did prepare is live because I this Hawk
is a little bit less but i just thought
i should have show something to just
based on my experience that there's some
digital things to go by so just a quick
background on myself and I'm you kai
chou i was born in taiwan and about high
school I hate grade and last semester of
eighth grade so you know I moved to the
space and the Kansas which was great for
the place to learn English friends
usually actually it's actually really
funny because people they're good
friends on my not even stream they
thought I look exactly like Jackie Chan
and gently at the same time right and
they were really serious said I started
my uh my first company offers here in
college when i was at UCLA and I
eventually moved on to do a few more
last one was reward me down a CEO about
six seven months when I talk a little
bit about that and then also a pioneer
in international keynote speaker for
gamification so now I speak about
gamification Denmar India Australia a
few other places and i created the
occasion for analysis so when i first
started my company in college what i
thought was that you know before that i
spent a lot of time playing games and
you know i was very obsessed by games i
would try to master every game I plywood
Excel spreadsheets and optimize my game
the list kill math of the skier matter
of this way there's actually community
of gamers out there using Excel
spreadsheets to play better and so we're
we're very very serious gamers and we
sell the games we play but eventually
you have to quit the game and hopefully
girls
seven year playing I gave your play
under 14 a strange right so so you guys
have to put the game and then I was quit
I quit a game called be able to and I
just felt no my life felt really empty
nice and thousands of hours mastering
this game and you know now I have
nothing right so since that I mean I
became really obsessed with how to
combine games with things that are
productive either making more productive
or make life more fun so I dove into
things where how can you use the
addictive fun exciting nature things of
games and corporate into things that are
important so college I started ft world
and basically back then virtual worlds
were pigs of second life I don't know
second life all right the second life
was pretty big it was a virtual to the
flu around Chad socialize and I saw a
second life ads the myspace official
world all about self-expression you know
you can customize everything but it's a
little you know messy a little dirty and
a lot of weird things going on here and
there yes I'm not sure we're actually oh
yeah awesome hear my voice yeah so so I
thought that hey there could be a
virtual world that's more of the living
space basically it's not about a fake
identity escapism but more about using a
virtual world to lower the bear of
meeting new people but represent your
professional self you know you can use
that to do network to you to do career
fairs to even do remote job interviews
so I worked on that is we also explored
a few different things like like you
know a remote office like virtual team
kind of project left the office
basically you know when you work in a
remote team and almost feels like all
your coworkers are just emails right and
you don't feel like you're part of a
culture so I thought hey what it would
be cool if this was just like a desktop
where where you're working working but
when people log into their computer it
shows the person get on their seat and
you kind of you don't have to interact
with them but you kind of see how their
mood is add you know their Tokyo or
wherever and they can you know you can
chat them whenever they want you can
open a open a why
bored or open a Skype you know directly
through that it just builds a little
more culture in that so these projects
especially one cleft II career was doing
okay one was rated uh I think one of the
top it was rate as a top ten social
networks for gen y's by mashable and we
had a partition with Disney
unfortunately and the one that had the
most theme was something that helped I
utilize gaming to help companies recruit
talent more efficiently now
unfortunately that was when the economy
crash of 2008 happened and every company
is looking to lay off everyone they
could so my you know my startup that
helped them hire more efficiently wasn't
very useful so we pivoted into few other
things so social media ranking biology
and the last thing I was doing is
something called reward me which is
really trying to bring the power of a
loyalty program and also customisation
personalization into the offline store
on restaurants and you know we raised a
million dollars for that and we pushed
that we accomplished good amount of
things and unfortunately seven months
ago we had some investor and co-founder
issues so I stepped down as CEO and I'm
not really so doing too much with that
anymore and so but that freed up my time
to do I'm really passionate about which
the gamification and so I develop a
framework about taluses basically really
bowling motivation down to eight core
drives and you through those April
driving you can start to figure out what
game mechanics and elements you should
use instead of just always say hey we
should put on points and badges and
leaderboards because we're doing
gamification and so that that really
took a took off and was translated about
seven different languages which is why I
get to fly around the world and just
talk about that so in relation to the
topic today I just have two slides with
some some bullet points but what comes
to the funding right I think we had we
we talked about the little earlier we
heard about the earlier there's a lot of
investors from my knowledge from China
who are very very wealthy but they made
money through traditional businesses and
they're not very sophisticated with
technology startups and but they also
value things from the west so so they
feel like hey you know if something's
from the West it's great technology
company they're great and they want to
figure out what to do with their money
so a lot of especially early days they
they come to the states they're trying
to find ways to invest
money in new technologies and there's a
few stories that I quickly want to talk
to talk about but notice that that has
been shifting lately also that that was
extremely the cases maybe five eight
years ago but now that money is shifting
back again into China because they're
feeling hey we're more sophistication
and a lot we have actually a bigger
market so so that is shifting a little
bit which which is important and then
example I want to talk about is this
company called TeleNav it's a public
company they were one of reward miza
investors and they had a really
interesting story so their founder HP
Jin is from China and he you know he be
prior to raise Dave successful round I
think was he raised 16 million dollars
but then he he got into a problem where
his his uh his funding was running out
and he couldn't raise more money so he
lowered his valuation to three million
dollars and still no one wanted to give
him money so you know he started cutting
off its employees you know going from
75% salary to 50 25 percent to the point
we told everyone hate just go home take
a break and you know we'll see what
happens so you know his company was
about to die but then he randomly met a
guy from China who was traveling here
and he's talked about the guy talked to
the guy about his I you know TeleNav and
because no interesting how much money do
you need he's like I need a million
dollars so the guys like okay and the so
big I gave him a million dollars and so
TeleNav HP Jen took that million dollars
and turn into a public company so that
China investor had a third of a public
company which obviously worked out
really well for him but you know rarely
you have you see that experience in the
u.s. if you if you you meet someone you
say hey you know I have a cool idea and
then here's a million-dollar check some
some people in social in Silicon Valley
not in other states would give you like
a seat like a if it's in some case
they'll give you like a seed fund up
like hey here's 25k 50k you don't see
like hey here's a million dollars for
you another example is gem play games
which is another friends company of mine
he has a gaming company this is about
six seven years ago ago I think and he
just went to a conference in Korea you
know and he was just hang out there and
then he just buy chances randomly he met
with the CEO of a public company in
Korea and it's a solar company not even
about games and they had a good
discussion and there is some side
stories to that I trouble
going to but at the end of end of the
day that see also that company gave him
a million dollars for his gaming company
in the US so again it just you just
meets people in the day here's a check
right but that obviously does it have it
all the time and oftentimes the other
other things happen right sometimes
these investors want you to go to China
to what they want you to too they think
again the valley or expertise they
Valley Western education experience so
they have money but they don't want to
just throw money into the u.s. they want
to find these towns and bring these
people to China or other Asian Nations
and so that's example of G upon which is
I could think via the biggest Foursquare
alike in China that my friends started
and so he you know he started his first
two or three businesses in the US and
then then he got almost recruit
attracted to Chyna based on the
opportunity and he raised money there
it's doing pretty well and then Yoda
wants another gaming company where my
friend was entrepreneur here and he got
recruited to China to start this company
Yoda one and and I think it raised I
think close 10 million dollars so so you
know there's there's a few examples of
how China is China as a mindset of if
funding is involving right before
there's like uh you know there's nothing
around here the u.s. is great let's put
money there and oftentimes it's great
because when they invest money they
don't ask a lot of questions because
there's like well you guys know what
you're doing nowadays they feel like you
know there they have more infrastructure
there and so they want to keep their
money there and even pull people to that
to that place also in terms of empire
provide environment so now in a lot of
Asian countries Singapore China Taiwan
there are technology parks just
districts you know kind of like a
Silicon Valley guess that's their goal
which is a district that's just about
technology research development starting
businesses and they give you a lot of
perks you know I've been personally
recruited to a lot of these places they
say hey if you come here and start a
business here will give you like to
350,000 seed funding will give you free
space for two years will give you the
government will help you here and there
so you know they're they're working
really hard they understand the value of
bringing entrepreneurs to to their to
their space which is which is the
opposite of my experience here because I
you know
as Professor dashing you knows that I
had a huge amount of struggles with
being entrepreneur here because I I
didn't have a valid legal status here
you know I finished school as
international student and then you know
I had a lot of trouble trying to staying
here because there are visas for
employees but there are no visas for
entrepreneurs and so I was on this these
documentaries about that topic also
obviously in Asia there's also a lot of
engineering resources these days all at
a lower cost is because that you know
standard living is lower there so a lot
of them are pushing for US companies to
try to outsource their R&D the
development into China or into Singapore
to Taiwan and sometimes it makes a lot
of sense there are obviously
communication problems there's their
time zone problems and communicate your
problems for you when you're dealing
with the different culture you can never
assume they they know what you're
talking about it has to be very very
clearly you can you can think that
you're super redundant but still not be
clear enough you know just like if you
just for instance if you don't say you
need want to log out button they won't
have a logout button right it's just you
have to sit and and if you just say it's
a log up button sometimes you they'll
say there's a button that says log out
but if you click on it does nothing
because you did not clarify the log a
button is supposed to log you out of the
site it's it just as well it's a button
that says log out on it all right it
just you just have to be that clear when
you communicate with overseas engineers
um but you know there's a lot of them
out there so every year you know China
graduates over a million engineers and
India 500,000 so at least last time I
tricking them I think they every year
they they're graduating more engineers
in the u.s. can buy like all of us as
engineers so so obviously you know
there's a lot of them they're they're
all there a lot of them are very smart
intelligent they can develop things that
you want so obviously that creates a
shift in the global workplace and
economy right and again a lot of them
also before these bigger companies who
made a lot of money in ages they're also
trying to expand into the US now like
way ball and some bigger gaming
companies and whatnot so they're they're
trying to see if there's ways to acquire
companies here are there ways to just
start a office here so now you'll start
to see more
of that happening too so that's my
experience in observations on Asia and
how it relates to you know entrepreneur
here and hopefully that was that was
useful to you guys so why don't you sit
down so I get asked first question the
you know kind of self-assessment of
Silicon Valley is that we are sort of to
the whole startup world what Hollywood
is to movies if you really count you're
going to be here you're really going to
be seeing the very best processes of
company formation and the very best
processes of growth here is that a kind
of kool-aid that everyone drinks here
should we be looking for other flavors
from other places too and anybody on the
panel want to start off with that one
hey I know is that a movie yeah that is
our major sometimes x-rated do the
process you start on set something off
days for your leave me yeah but what I
mean is that we're really the center of
that kind of nature of business that the
valley is where you really ought to come
to learn did you come so i moved here
from Los Angeles and the reason why I
moved here was I heard a lot of people
talk about how you should you need to be
still in Silicon Valley if you're going
to be entrepreneur and I think beef it's
still very very valid it's and I think
it'll be it'll be valid for a long time
but obviously there's a lot more
alternatives so the what problem me to
come here was when i when i was i was
listening to one of the ones as staff an
entrepreneur thought leadership series
interview or a talks and i remember it
was the the founder of google analytics
and they asked him hey you know how does
being an LA help you be an entrepreneur
help you build your startup and cell to
google and he says none like if I I'm
censure if I was in Silicon Valley when
I started GU analyst from starting to to
sound to google that entire time will be
halved you know just kind of fifty
percent and I thought that was really
compelling so so I moved here and I was
understanding why that is the case and
you know what I think it is true because
there's a lot of infrastructure you know
the law firms that people understand
startups over in in LA back then there's
maybe like one startup event every two
one or two months and most of a lot of
them aren't even good but over here
there's like twenty every week you can't
even go into all of them so so there's a
community of understanding so that has
been the case for a long time but
obviously there's a lot of hubs
internationally and even in LA and you
know in other states that are still
building that it's not as robust as
sophisticated as Silicon Valley but it's
definitely trying to catch up as I think
the panel agrees that Silicon Valley
really is a very sophisticated place and
place where all sorts of resources are
available for starting up interest right
so why care about Asia there's the
question for the panel session right
yeah everybody though so so i think i
would start just by saying yes as
another member of the panel i agree that
Silicon Valley definitely has the
technologies for starting companies and
some of the resources for doing that but
that doesn't mean it has all the
resources you need and I think you can
actually and I alluded to this perhaps
in my comments but I think there's a
risk of falling into Silicon Valley
think around how you start a company and
what kind of problems are worth working
on and what a good company looks like
and so I think there are entrepreneurs
and there are ideas that are just a
great fit with everything that's here in
Silicon Valley right out of the gate and
you don't need to go anywhere else but I
think a lot of the time it can be very
helpful to get some other perspectives
and so I think it is generally true
in innovating in any way that you're not
going to have all the good ideas you're
not going to happen to have all the best
ideas and the best resource is sitting
in your library it tends to be true with
corporate R&D and that's why we see the
rise of open innovation you don't
generally have the best expert in
everything in your R&D lab in the same
way when you're starting a company the
best ideas around some things or sources
of capital and other things do you need
to draw on maybe outside okay Jim let me
follow through real quickly you're you
started out kind of last year right and
so in terms of starting a company this
past year versus having started the
company's you did earlier or you Caillou
started companies earlier oh do you see
changes in the process and the valley
just in the last two years since 2008
personally I think the economy improved
and they think the overall economic
investment environment much better and
that helps when you go out and you pitch
and people are not down and out and they
don't have that you know a dark cloud
over the head yeah but I I think that
for me pitching to Silicon Valley
investors still at at least at the very
very early phase is very difficult
because they are short-term thinking and
and they don't you know a useful my kind
of project they just don't take that
kind of risk you're caught you're
nodding about the about the oftentimes
short short-term thinking part but let
me rephrase this I think short-term
thinking also may have to do with a
clear sense of exit they want to make
sure they can get their money out
preferably sooner rather than later
right yes but that's that's another
that's the short-term thinking part
isn't is another conversation in the
sense that you know they they usually
are interested in what everyone else is
interested already in so so and I've you
know I have friends who work at VP says
that hey you know they they rejected a
start-up because you know they're crappy
in 10 different ways and then a week
later they realize it
better funded a similar company and they
like crap we need to call them back and
fund them right but you know it's like
doesn't make any steam self recognizes
it doesn't make any sense because they
still cook they're still crapping those
ten ways but you know now we now we know
we want them all right so it's just not
about they want us and they want to see
enough traction to the point where they
can sell it but you know this talk isn't
is precisely about that so I to answer
your original question and not talking
about the technology trends I think in
the past few years there's the movement
towards the Latina having a lean startup
right the lean movement in terms of not
raising a ton of money and building up a
big thing before you test the market so
I think that's one of the big things and
I to I think there's there's a shrinkage
in the series a investor so there's
still growth and see funders you know
you can still get few hundred thousand
dollars to start your project and
there's a lot of Sirius B and C
investors basically you're growing
you're making a lot of money and they
want to dump more money so you can grow
faster and get to an exit but serious a
investors which are those who say yo you
have a product you have early traction
you know company who are you know
customers early customers they don't you
know there's a shrinking amount of vc
investment in that space because they
still feel like this is really risky
it's kind of it's still far away from
the exit that you talked about and so
that that part has been shrinking okay
shall we open the floor ed break open
the discussion a little bit by by
challenging Richards use of the term
Asia it's like saying United States
there are vast differences we can name
Silicon Valley then we can age five
other entrepreneurial quote regions on
both then we can name Mississippi where
there isn't any and etc etc could could
the panelists say something about the
differences the two nations are not one
thing there are many things in there
quite different I think that's a very
good point and I would like to open it
up we've got three people representing
more or less three different sort of
sectors right Japan South East Asia more
or less kind of the China focus for you
kind
look at what makes those sectors
different or distinctive David so chhota
played a bit part in my presentation and
I dearly love toto but basically when I
talk about Japan you can substitute
Tokyo so as far as entrepreneurial
activity in Japan that I'm aware of
generally or that is relevant to our
company it's basically Tokyo and Tokyo
is an incredible cluster but there's not
much outside it as far as
entrepreneurship is concerned when I was
doing thank you for raising like when I
was doing my online music company when
we talk about Vietnam the car with the
EMI of the Sony universal people
actually they think of Vietnam maspeth
you know Cambodia and Laos Vietnam plus
Singapore Vietnam plus Malaysia so is
that is that Southeast Asia neighborhood
that's one market we don't you know we
don't refer to when we talk about
opportunity in Southeast Asia we don't
think of Korea Japan that's the the
marketing side market entry side in
regard to the dynamics of startups it is
very different in different Asia places
one of the things I'd like to comment on
is everybody brings our own personal
background and kind of you know where
you've been and the people you know and
to a certain extent you go with what
your strengths are and I I'd like to
throw the ball to you Kai and ask you to
talk a little bit about what has been
distinctive you know either culturally
from Taiwan or with working with China
or whatever so in Taiwan and China are
very very difficult not talking about
politically but just like
entrepreneurial system and structure
Taiwan is a lot more conservative it's
it's more in the you know maintenance
stage now in its economy just just it
had its good growth stage about 30 years
ago I think and so it's it's doing very
lightweight amount of you know start-up
technology involvement but China on the
other hand is going through explosive
growth and it's recognizing sup as the
powerhouse a lot of people are becoming
wealthy really quickly without knowing
what to do with that money and also part
of it is also they went through the
Chinese Revolution right
which was really really the sense of you
know they need to rep you need to rev
like everything everything everything
you throw away your books you do all the
stuff so I think that builds a culture
of doing radical things like they think
they almost wiped out a decent amount of
China's 5,000 his years of history and
so you know that obviously that's that's
good and bad the same time sense that it
allows you to be innovative that allows
you to take risks and think about how to
how to create more innovation obviously
some people say oh we lost big part of
our tradition so so when you look at you
know and also Singapore is the country
where you know it's it's very well
maintained but they're also trying you
know it's very government regulate its
just government is very active in trying
to push for the economy and you know
they're very active in making sure
making Singapore a very small but very
comfortable place to grow an economy and
to grow your startup and and create
engineering staff so I said these are
like some of the differences i do want
to respond a little bit to add because
remember we've been doing a 9 session
series and the sessions up to today have
all really been about what's going on in
a particular area and there is a huge
diversity and you know multicolored
nature of the different kind of
environments you'll find different Asia
economies today the focus is what are
you bringing from Asia to the valley
right what does the valley gain out of
what's going on in Asia not so much
what's going on in Asia but I don't want
this to what like we're trying to paint
everything with the same brush right it
really is things are very different in a
an economy where the average you know
income per person is really higher than
the United States cause Singapore's is
at least twenty thousand dollars higher
average individual income in the US is
versus a place like you know China or
even Southeast Asia where there's still
an awful lot of room to grow before you
get up to
US income per person oh that's open for
again with a local angel group but more
than the life signs there is the life
signs angels just want to comment
personally on about the series a week at
the angel groups realized there is that
big gaps so the angel capture
Association trying to syndicate a lot
more fill that gap but there there is a
problem of the part I want to ask about
the panel is with a lot of these science
parks these incubators not happening
just just in Asia but you know built
locally what's you know what what we all
against impression of these them or have
you have you dealt with them previously
are you referring to Y Combinator types
or co-working spaces but i'd say that
the co-working space is the incubator y
combinator type is an accelerator okay
what certain put a definition on it
panelists and how much experience have
you done with with with in tomato type
is that cause you didn't meet them
because we didn't need them and we own
you know is more like local companies I
tend to think you know personally that
of the resource availability in Silicon
Valley means that you really have to
have a pretty exceptional program to be
successful as something like Y
Combinator just because if you don't
need it why bother yeah let me ask you
are you getting people from outside the
valley community who want to join the
angel group you mean as angel members or
right right either as investors or as
mentors or somehow be involved with your
angel group and they're coming from Asia
or not really resident here in the
valley we do have a lot of folks with
Asian background okay that's not like
you know over came over people wait here
more difficult if you actually live in
Asia because how would you know fly
every month attended in a media or
if you have a teleconference there it
just makes it makes it challenging but
there is more partnership than this yeah
that was a point about going with Asia
and back how how do you handle the
long-distance nature of business
relationships with Asia especially where
you're fifteen hours behind it just
makes calling them its review or they
call you on skype oh yeah you're not
ours so so for the incubator Soleri
programs i think they were extremely
positive here because it almost feels
like you're your entrepreneur you start
your first visit but you're not in the
wild anymore it's almost like certain
school right because before your yet
you're used to your corporate
environment and you know things are set
there but you start if you start a
company you're like wow everything is
different like everything's a variable
what can I do so so you have to figure
out every single little block but in an
incubator program at least it gives you
more structure about oh these are these
are the straight for these are strippers
so you just have to worry about creating
value for customers building a product
and having that community I think that
is very positive obviously with some
with a more prominent one like Y
Combinator once you graduate you
immediately come with some c funding
because again foreign investors from
Russia and other places they just say
hey every every class who graduates from
my company i'm going to put a little bit
money into them right and so I maybe
that's going to happen for for asian
asian investors also not sure and then
the q co-working spaces those are you
know obviously not as powerful but they
just allow entrepreneurs to have you
know to to build a community fail again
it's just feeling that you're not out
there doing it by yourself and I think
even in Silicon Valley without those
when you start a company it's still very
lonely right it's still you're just
working by yourself and you don't know
what you're doing and you don't know
what's the next step what was going to
happen and then let it like obvious
that's the same for every everywhere so
so it's good to have that community of
people who are in the same shoes as you
are and taking the same risks let me
follow through with
a different question this is sort of
different cultural patterns of doing
business I'd like to ask each panelist
starting with David how two different
say business culture issues impact the
way you're going to localize your
product here than in Asia or well for
module q2 the whole sense of how groups
work in Japan is very different than it
is here and the same thing for Jim right
I'm with kindan you know you're going to
have different kinds of dynamics going
on ukai in the whole gamification space
how do you handle cultural differences
the David won't you go first and so we
with the disclaimer that we haven't yet
started localizing our technology for
Japan what we find is that Japanese
organizations tend to be very focused on
risk avoidance and control and so we
have strong interest from a large
Japanese bank in our product when US
companies look at our technology
generally they are looking at G this
could make our individual knowledge
workers a lot more productive and it
could give us better management
analytics so we could start seeing into
the processes that we manage when I talk
to Japanese organizations it tends to be
much more along lines of G we had
somebody accidentally CC somebody that
they shouldn't have and the CEO had to
go and apologize for this internal
information being sent to the wrong
person if we could use module 2 to
control who sees what and where things
go that would be great they also tend to
be you know Japanese organizations are
generally very concerned about you talk
about sort of incestuous relationships
with suppliers and so forth and so the
bank's routinely rotate their sales reps
so the sales reps shifts accounts every
two years and that's highly disruptive
to the business right if you've been
dealing with one person for your sales
account for bird and this is commercial
lending these are big lungs and your
rotating every one every two years and
so and if you're doing with email how do
you move that work in progress ok i'll
forward everything from my inbox right
and so something like module two could
give you control over processes like
that so now the organization's fun
very differently but the limitations of
email as a process management tool are
still there okay Oh Jim you know our
first investor sees investment kinda
tees from Vietnam and he sees a measure
for richer manufacturer there and I was
really intrigued when he said he wanted
to invest because I know that that in
our culture in my culture the art of
saying thank you is quite formal you
know and and whereas in kind it we want
to make the Thank You process fun simple
and quick but in the Asian culture
especially in Vietnamese culture is
saying thank you it's like you know they
say huge way in your shoulder and how
you say it you know your facial
expression when you say it it is very
elaborate right and so I was very
intrigued when he said well you know how
can you simplify this process so that
can work with Lao culture for the vid
miss culture anyway I was quite proud of
that and we came up with with ways that
to simplify this but I think that will
you know when we when we launched we
will know for sure if we have the right
way and that is you know we have to make
the process really easy but the you know
the UI UX interface for that particular
audience has to be done right so that it
works for that particular market just a
brief follow-up on your business model
you're actually going to have ways of
saying thank you that are essentially
monetary rewards that you can do online
it's it's it's free but what the the
third tier about thing is you know
recognize me coordinate work so you
recognize the kind act and you record
the connect using your mobile phone and
the last is you reward meaning you know
if Richard did something nice I said hey
thanks for helping me here it's a
twenty-dollar starbucks gift card for
you for helping me Richard can say that
he can you can take that I can send it
to him and I get kind of mix a
percentage from that transaction right
but if Richard said hey don't worry
about him I just want to help you out
when you give that twenty dollars to
salvation army or the good
well okay so that twenty dollars can
also go to a charitable organization and
we don't make any money from that that
goes to a nonprofit organization okay
okay we talked a little bit at lunch the
other day about how this would fit very
well the whole idea of giving gifts back
once you receive gifts in Asian cultures
do a great business in government no
comment you got what about gamification
cultural differences in gamification so
the nice thing about gamification is
really learning from games applying to
productive activities nice thing about
games is that it's pretty global it's
for an international right every every
nation that has the luxury to play games
they usually followed but like there's a
huge amount of people who fall in love
with games and it's not just young males
but you know for in the US there's
actually more woman over 30 playing
games than males under 20 but you know
obviously the details of how you create
a game will sometimes a little different
in different places so I think what's
useful and going back to the framer are
catalysis right it breaks down a quart
drive so the equal drives all relevant
everywhere so friends like epic meaning
and calling you're doing something
that's because of something that's
bigger than yourself right you're like
Wikipedia your contribute to Wikipedia
not because you are making money or
building a resume you've contributed
Wikipedia because you feel like you're
protecting humanity's knowledge or
empowerment of creative feedback like
everywhere people do want to feel like
hey I can utilize my creativity and I
want to see feedback of it so you know
there's some adjustments like some
cultures say hey you know if you're a
worker you don't want to you know you're
just you just you should just work hard
you should you don't Nestle need to have
you know ownership of a you know full
ownership over something or you don't
necessarily need to be empowered with
creativity but you know I think innately
all all human besom want these things
it's just you have to kind of understand
each culture how they're a little bit
different and be very sensitive to it to
it and you know just real quick follow
Talos asst comm or.org what's the web's
at alice's calm can can get you there
yeah it's a very good website octa ly s
is dot com okay um for is open go ahead
so Jim you had mentioned EGP high
emotions personal investment angels
that's not very compatible generally
with angel investment the idea being
that one you know one description here
in Silicon Valley is an angel investing
is like birds money and so that's not
very compatible with somebody looking to
store their money in a safe stable
investment that's likely to return
that's a treasury point there's not an
angel investment so how do you bridge
that in explaining that to those
investors who may or may not be
sophisticated to me the hippie profile
applies probably in the first couple
meetings with these guys you know is
they are highly charged because they
maybe they connect with you personally
you know they there's some commonality
between you know what I've gone through
what they have gone through for example
and so we have been pretty successful in
terms of making that linkage making that
connection with them in the first couple
of meetings just the idea that you know
I make sure my investment is safe but
that's always there but the hippie part
comes in very early and if we can
qualify them at that early stage and get
them to commit because they connect with
you because there's some emotional
connection there's some personal
connection and I think that help
compensate for the you know make sure my
money is safe part you understand they
do understand they do understand and
actually you know as you go through the
negotiation with them when you're close
and all that in the terms that's when
you know they take that sort out and
they you know they eyes they know so
it's uh it gets down to you know I'm
sitting with the lawyer and making sure
that you know hear that hear the
statistic terms that they want I just
want to comment
briefly because my experience in dealing
with Japanese investors has been very
different from the comments on dealing
with Chinese investors and I don't know
if that is is one of these cultural
differences or if it's you know that in
Silicon Valley there are lots of
different people with different
investment styles but what I have found
is that generally when we're talking
about investments in people who are
either Japanese or have really strong
Japan connections they tend to be
oriented around long relationships and
so almost all of these investments come
from people that I have long and long
relationships with meaning ten years or
more in many cases and that when there's
not a long relationship it's a very
trusted introduction from someone that
there's one of those relationships with
I found those investors to be very dry
so anything but the emotional model they
know me they look at the business plan
they make a pretty cut-and-dried
decision and there's never any
negotiation on terms I have a question
on that so I've heard a lot in slick
about its unique where you know people
are more except with failures right so
when you in Japan when you're when you
raise some money from someone you've
known for 10 years they trust you as a
person long-term relationship and if
some if the entrepreneur loses the money
does that burn the relationship or
they're like okay that that was a good
run in almost all of these cases perhaps
all when we're talking about Japanese
nationals these are people who have had
long international lots of international
so I think it'd be very rare that you'd
find sort of a traditional Japanese
mainline domestic business millionaire
willing to take risky investments in
Silicon Valley and there are there are
more traditional Japanese individuals
that I know who are wealthy from whom I
have not sent solicited money because I
suspect that they might not deal well
with that I think there's also a
difference between early-stage versus
later stage at the early stage you're
really talking about more personal
investments period no matter whether
you're talking about an angel
here or you're talking about going to an
angel somewhere else at the later stage
you know venture capital in Asian
countries tends to be more from a
financial standpoint than it does from a
strategic technology analysis and I do
think that that different still persists
to the extent that sometimes it's hard
to demonstrate something it's hard to
get people to buy something unless you
can show a relatively early return in
Asia I think you'd have a very hard time
raising a Series A or A Series B or a
series c in Japan unless you have
silicon valley funds on board yeah okay
what should the valley worry about in
the future this is a last question for
the day should we be concerned that
we're going to lose something about the
special nature of the valley should we
be looking at Asia for anything is Asia
a good partner as Asia and upcoming
competitor what should our attitude be
here I'm worried I'm talking too much
here I feel like the biggest concern is
really talent drain I think again all
like not just Asia all the other
countries are aggressively recruiting
entrepreneurs to go to their country and
start businesses and in the US the US
has been working relentlessly hard to to
prove stop entrepreneurs from working
here right and again that's that's a
huge story from for me but so so that's
that's one thing right I mean what makes
Silicon Valley unique is not the
interest rate out the building it's the
people's entrepreneur it's because it
has a bride named where entrepreneurs
travel here to start businesses and to
support each other and the beat in the
investors are here but if that if that
reverses where the entrepreneurs all
want to go somewhere else then obviously
Silicon Valley's just it's just place
with buildings right and roads largely I
don't I won't say that it was like just
suddenly become something different but
you know as a trend it could 10 20 years
later become something that's that
that doesn't want to be and also we look
at for our engineering resources to your
right you know what's just staying
relevant because because now we're it's
a it's a global competitive market and I
feel like part part of that is just
really knowing what you're good at and
when the globalization is not
necessarily a bad thing but it's just
more about now you have to really
understand what you do best and focus on
that and in your point of reference is
now global instead of just what you can
see around you app actually I'm going to
ask Jim to go next sure for me I think
you know we have all the all the
ingredients here to last a while but you
know we need to continue making this
place accessible and open to everybody
make it easy for them to to come here
and i think one one other thing I'll
government did very well is the eb-5
program you know make it easier for
overseas investors to to invest here and
and you know get the money back and you
know they get the green car and all that
yeah this is new when is this coming
into effect I think I think it's already
it is in fact now I guess doing quite
well actually but you have to have at
least 220 k 500 500 500 what Silicon
Valley a million bags ya know so yes so
that's so that blocks out most Silicon
Valley entrepreneurs who are young
people out of school tutor you know and
there will be an increase in the number
of green cards I think your ID badges
and the Senate broke a green card okay
like John Hennessy talking about
stapling green cards to everybody's
degree it's going to happen okay David
um so I think I would tend to agree with
those on the panel and and in the
audience who are more sanguine on the
human resources dimension in part
because in starting our company here one
of the things we've recognized is that
particularly for for IT related internet
related talent and to it to a lesser
extent venture law
intellectual property but especially
technology talent you know the epicenter
is in San Francisco and you know it's
snowballing if anything so it's more and
more attracted there so what I worry
most about is the the financial capital
taps being turned off because if you
look at the distribution of capital
venture capital around the world in very
rough numbers according to our friends
at pwc it's a third in Silicon Valley
and it fluctuates a certain amount over
the years but a third in Silicon Valley
a third in the rest of the United States
and a third in the rest of the world if
you think about that for a moment the
size of this geography and the share of
global venture capital that is
concentrated here it's outrageously out
of proportion and it more than explains
the way that we've been able to to
create virtuous cycles here but my
understanding and I would defer to
experts on this is that venture capital
returns have not been so great IPO is
getting a lot harder or has gotten a lot
harder post the dot bomb but Jim
mentioned earlier on and as a result the
institutional money that has fed this
virtuous cycle of entrepreneurial
activity is tapering off and I don't
know how significant that tapering is
perhaps it's not something to be worried
about but if I if I were going to worry
about anything that would be okay I have
a couple of thank yous i want to say i
want to say thank you first to tiffany
our course assistant to see Jen who has
done all the advertising for this
I want to say thanks to all of you both
students who've registered for credit
because without students we wouldn't be
doing this and also those of you who
come you know week after week for a lot
of our regulars we're really delighted
that you found value in these and are
very happy that you've come I want to
say thanks to our sponsors major series
support for this came from is I densa
and Jim is in the audience today so will
you know be sure and say hi also thank
the Allen minor foundation for support
of this series oh and you know certainly
I'd like to join everybody and saying
thanks to a panel of Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs to keep all of this in
perspective thank you gentlemen
you